je vous le disais en titre du nouveau
sur le front du vaccin anti qu'ovide le
laboratoire récit pharma a été choisi
par la biotech américaine moderna pour
produire une partie de son vaccin contre
le coronavirus en france et le groupe b
doivent aller fabriquer sur son site de
nyon en indre et loire ce vaccin basé
sur la technologie innovante de la rn
messager serait efficace à 94 5 %
explications de samuel colin en europe
le vaccin de moderna sera fabriqué dans
deux laboratoires l'un est en suisse et
l'autre à mon juste derrière moi ce site
de recife armes est spécialisé dans les
médicaments injectables concrètement
c'est ici que vont être conditionné les
doses de ce vaccin contre la copie de 19
matières premières bien quand je les et
vraiment très très concentré et après on
fait donc la préparation pour les
flacons qui vont être utilisés par les
médecins au niveau de l'axé nation pour
l'instant l'accord avec l'entreprise de
biotech américaine n'est pas encore
finalisé pour autant les aménagements
sur les lignes de production ont eux
déjà commencé car vous le savez ces
vaccins à arn messagers doivent être
conservés à des températures négatives
250 personnes travaillent sur ce site et
une soixantaine vont être recrutés car
les commandes sont déjà là l'union
européenne a ainsi passé contrat pour
160 millions de doses qui seront
distribués à ses états membres
aux etats unis la production du vaccin
de moderna à elle déjà commencé